[Music]
welcome back to careful boys where the
caution is at an all-time high all the
time every day every day every day i
think we're gonna get a little divisive
here because um the question of the day
is
should your girl have your phone
passcode so we already know anthony says
yes so i'll just i'll speak for him
and we can just go around the room
clockwise now what are you
why do you think his yes right away
because he's a massive [ __ ] oh okay
well throw my name in the hat as well
steve green okay because i am also in
solidarity with my man volunteering his
tribute yeah cause my girl won't she
won't check my phone i wish she would
why do you have do you have it locked i
do just for apple pay that's the only
reason why because you don't want her
spending her money
no like because you have to have a
passcode on your phone if you want to
use apple payments oh that's true very
interesting stuff i know but like that's
right it's good for security though
you need a passcode you know that [ __ ]
yeah so you just need a passcode you
want you want her to you don't want her
to find but you do want her to find all
the naked dude pics yeah but she won't
ever look she won't ever look so i leave
my phone up there on the table all the
time and i just wait for her to like see
if she's going to look at there she
doesn't even bother with anthony let me
carry yeah why is yours an automatic
guess why is it like why because steve
said so
he didn't answer at all
how right is she let's just let's go to
the next person
i didn't believe in it because i talked
to other women but then um when i
decided
that it's time to be good
i said you can have my passcode
but
so they can see the conversations that i
had with other women
but then also i said to myself
i need a contingency plan
if i die
who do i trust i trust bart yeah i don't
have i don't have a password i know but
you don't yeah that's true
but bart might be busy because if i die
we might not be able to get to him for a
week you know you're not gonna get
around to it yeah i mean you i hope you
die like after five p.m
because you that's so you just have to
deal with the [ __ ] that's why you're
more free
so he hopes i die between five to seven
thirty at the most yeah so if you hold
on just a little bit
if i get a text from bart
at 10 40 i'm like okay so something [ __ ]
[ __ ] went down at bart's house
something's up hannah geo had a [ __ ]
huge fight or some i don't know what's
going on right now 10 40s 10 40. i'm
like dude this guy i don't know what
happened it must be an emergency exactly
damn
yeah but it's i think it's good for a um
like a contingency plan like okay you
know you just have each other's info you
[ __ ] geotag whatevers so your girl
has your info yeah because i'm like if i
die
these are the things you do this is my
exit plan this is my this is what you
move this is who you tell wow
i just told nikki to talk to my little
brother because he knows
how to use all my crypto stuff yeah
because otherwise there's no explaining
to her how to use this [ __ ]
chick's brains don't work like advanced
like we like our brains women am i right
women don't [ __ ] get it that's true
she actually just like hey look i like
i'll start to tell her about it and
she's like just [ __ ] have candy do it
i don't want to do it
halfway through yeah jio can't even
spell crypto
we should ask her next time she's here
spell crypto geo the case she's like too
busy knitting sometimes
maybe if she chatted it to her hand she
could know how to spell crypto well if i
put it like in her nail polish she might
actually be able to read it oh that's
pretty good that's pretty good i think
that's what you do you should put the
[ __ ] key inside of the nail
she can see it and then you know let me
tell you that's the wallet key the
crypto wallet key i'm pretty sure nikki
has all of my passwords just because the
amount of time that we've been together
like and like like for example like if
if
we're in around the house
and she's
she's like i need to do an instagram
story my [ __ ] thing's not working
what the [ __ ] i just need to film this
real quick like franklin's doing this
thing and i'm like okay cool just take
my phone and then she's like she's she
knows my password because over the years
[ __ ] i'm sorry
i was projecting because i hate myself
[Laughter]
when you guys steve you're so good when
you guys are cheating on your women
right like what do you do
when you guys are cheating what do you
do to hide it okay so here's something
that women don't know about yet that i'm
gonna okay so if you're watching this
with a chick around
just just come with an excuse
so
there's this tab
called the incognito tab shut up steve
nobody shut up dude
what you could do is you can you can
there's this cool thing you can minimize
your screen and your screen shrinks down
goes down the bottom right there a
little in the little tray yeah all right
and then chicks have no you put whatever
you want down there chicks they have no
idea wow i don't even know how to use it
i don't know about it yet they don't
know they can't check your history
because there is none nothing down there
dude they don't know what history is
it's gone my baby look why don't you go
ahead and look through my history
how about you go look for it my guy
friends there all kind of do that to him
and he's like yeah yeah yeah
i think it depends on the stage of
relationship you're in because like
you know for us it's like that where
um if you have a family there's
contingency plans so she has access to
all of my [ __ ] like my face can open her
phone her face can open my phone i know
her login to all her banks she knows log
into mine i have a file of all my
passwords
um she has a file of all and how do you
hide the other women though that's what
we're asking that's that's the tough
part
i think other women but it's it's hot
it's harder to do when they know your
password did you ever or did you ever
know anybody who had a second phone for
cheating uh i did yes a second phone for
cheating that's a lot of work
your friend uh your friend peeve
how the [ __ ] did you know his name i'm
actually serious about that how did you
know his name no seriously can we
actually pee
no do you actually know do you actually
know him peeve yeah absolutely dude next
to pet right that's crazy yeah he's kind
of [ __ ] up okay that's not bad i enjoy
that one
fan service for anthony i
man
it gets there right you don't go on the
first date and go here you go oh thank
you yeah
all right okay what's your name
my face
it definitely took a few uh
years and i think it was all a slow
build up too and i'm not saying i had
this [ __ ] like road map for this [ __ ]
you know
but like you know first it may be
started off with like cool you could log
into like my amazon if you need to like
pick some stuff up for the house because
we live together okay then i was like
you know what like since you go to whole
foods and i have an amazon credit card
for amazon and you have my amazon
account use the amazon credit card for
whole foods because i have it on my
phone already just hold the credit card
you know what i mean then it turned into
like those just same thing like regular
house stuff it's like hey i need to use
your phone for something what's your
password you know the music what's the
netflix password how the [ __ ] do i get
into netflix why did you do why didn't
you do the normal password that you do
but then i i also know her logins and
stuff like that but i feel like and and
i haven't formally talked to about this
with steve yet so i i should probably do
it right now but she has my past codes
and then she knows because i've told her
i was like should i anything happen to
me you have my codes to give to steve
oh wow okay so that he can handle this
[ __ ] that you won't understand can i
point my lady to hit you up too for my
crypto stuff yeah for all 37
hey dude stop telling my net worth bro
[ __ ] my [ __ ] just chilling in there
you gotta go that's two dollars you
might give my code to steve
it's 27 dogecoin blowing up my spot
everyone i'm a rich guy this is a formal
moment by the way
i already
give my code to steve steve gets five
percent of whatever and then make sure
uh make sure he gives you the rent do
you know what five percent of thirty
eight dollars
yeah you know five percent of thirty
dollars
so i think fidelity wise a big reason
like not everybody's gonna watch this
obviously as relationships as long drawn
as ours are that it's a confident moment
to give that passcode but i think one of
the reasons that we all have done that
where it's like hey here's access to my
[ __ ] is cause you know you're not with
someone that's a [ __ ] crazy person
that's going to type your [ __ ] in and
[ __ ] go through every little thing
and try to find something that's also
true but we don't know yet well mickey
does too i don't know yet dude i barely
know how to check my instagram dms like
half of you guys dm me on instagram i
barely know how to [ __ ] to get to it
unless it comes up what i love is when
it comes up and i see the notifications
like hey joe just dm you and i'm like oh
cool and i click on it and then it goes
it does it for you otherwise i don't
know how to [ __ ] together i'm literally
like that i'm like a [ __ ] grandpa
where it's like if it takes more than
one finger i don't know
so i think we're all agreed that we've
never been forced to give it
never no i know some people though that
uh if you're forced don't [ __ ] get it
man you're in a really um untrustworthy
relationship then yeah you need to if
you have if you have if they have to
read your text messages and all that
that's [ __ ] toxic bro dumb [ __ ] right
there yeah do you guys like those memes
where everyone talks about like oh don't
let my girl get my phone or my passcode
delete my history if i die yeah yeah i
[ __ ] oh my gosh shut the [ __ ]
up shut the [ __ ] up please apple yes i
don't know it's like in the well should
you be with this person in the first
place if you if you're not comfortable
with them reading you flirting with
other women well
[Laughter]
that was nice
that snuck up on me today's video is
brought to you by dipsy check this out
it's been hectic okay everyone's working
from home
you're confronted with laundry you're
confronted with work it doesn't stop
when do you have time for yourself to
just enjoy the pleasures of life that's
why dipsy is pretty cool you know what
they do what do they do so dipsy stories
is full of sexy audio stories
and now they also have brand new written
ones too no matter who you're into or
what turns you on dipsy helps bring the
stories to life anytime anywhere that's
right because sometimes i'll be
listening to you know youtube or
watching some debate or whatever i'm
like i can't sleep watching this [ __ ]
it's too it's too it's too crazy too
stimulating it's too stimulating give me
a sexy story to listen to yeah i want
you to romance the [ __ ] out of my brain
and let me just use my imagination to
like think of something pleasant and
they have hundreds of stories to choose
from and they're releasing new stuff
every week so you won't get bored and
also they have wellness sessions to help
you just explore relax and help you
sleep because all of this is to help you
wind down so you don't have to be all
like anxiety filled so this sounds
interesting to you go to dipsy.com off
the record to get an extended free
30-day trial that's d-i-p-s-e-a
dot com slash off the record to have
access to the full library for 30 days
give it a try there's nothing to lose
dipsy.com off the record i think it's
definitely like it's a bad sign when
someone tries to like if they used us
for example and went you should give me
your passcode because i saw a video and
every guy at that table their girl had
the passcode so that's a symbol of trust
it's like no
it's yeah it's how it's done
give me some time to delete my history
let me prepare this page for you and
then from that point on baptize my
entire [ __ ] text history first the
symbol of trust is when the trust is
given given
hey there you go it's earned right when
you're married to it's just so natural
to know all your partner's [ __ ] like
nikki knows my social security number
off her head so that she's on the phone
[ __ ] and she's just like
i hear her doing it so it's like yeah
married is a different level because
there's gonna be a point in time in the
marriage when it's like hey i'm sorry
can you wipe my ass from now on yeah you
know i never [ __ ] make my wife do
that dude i make her [ __ ] eat my ass
instead how many of you do you guys do
you guys know your significant other's
phone number by heart i don't know any
phone numbers by heart i don't know i
need i always need a refresher she gets
mad at me for it i don't she she doesn't
know mine
and that bothers me dude what an
emergency it happened i'm saying i'm
like yeah dude there's a video for you
dude that's the one you're watching at
home you better memorize my will help
her what is it
truce story i was following nikki to get
her honda service whatever the [ __ ] and
so like i was following the dealership i
don't know where the [ __ ] dealership
is i don't ever know where i am even
though i lived in this particular area
for years
so i'm following her in my in my car and
she is a [ __ ] mad woman bro if she's
when she's behind the wheel that's
[ __ ] insane is she worse than you as
far as like uh like road rage is that
what you mean oh no no no no road rage
wise no nobody is this is hard to know
but nobody is but she is a lead foot so
she'll just [ __ ] blast off and she
blast off on this particular day when i
didn't have my phone and i was like god
damn it i don't know how the [ __ ] where
she went
so i had to pull over into a like a
subway just lost yeah i lost you [ __ ]
burned me out
and then i pulled someone's stealing me
yeah i walk into i walk into a subway or
like a [ __ ] not on the jamba juice or
some [ __ ] and i was like hey can i use
your phone uh uh and then what a such
[ __ ] thing these days i know right
and then they're like sure and they give
me the phone and then i was like okay
what the [ __ ] is your number oh no
that's the worst i just hit nicky
everybody had my phone back crackhead
this was like the first couple years and
i was like oh my god i don't know her
[ __ ] number so i had to i had to like
call
i had to like
the operator no i had to like sell my
girl number
somehow i got a hold of her internet and
i was able to email her dad what the
hell not even her email no because i
don't know how to log into her well well
i knew that not to email her because she
was driving so i was like okay well her
dad's oh it's tax season he's always at
his [ __ ] desk like
so and i'd already been talking to them
that morning about a and the email we
should talk each other on the email and
so so then i i was able to get a hold of
her through him he calls her after
getting my email but if not for that i
didn't know her [ __ ] number so after
that i knew we're [ __ ] right every
time
that's good man yeah that's a lot of
emergencies happen the mistake was they
didn't have gnaws
in your car
that would never happen a guy like me
i got caught in a light bro yeah
turbo through that thing
how much do you feel like you can um
trust your significant other with
because um
i've never felt like oh [ __ ] they're
gonna they're gonna [ __ ] ruin me i
think it's like a weird thing it's it's
not so much that like like on my end i
just i've had i've paid my [ __ ] dues
as being the [ __ ] jealous boyfriend
so many [ __ ] times some of the girls
have paid
yeah so like i understand now like i've
reached a point where it's not even that
i'm like oh i trust she's not doing
anything i don't give a [ __ ] like i'm
just like if you are
and it [ __ ] comes up and it ruins our
relationship that's the [ __ ] course
of time fun but i don't even i'm not
even at the point where i'm wondering
about i'm just like hey [ __ ] it yeah if
it happens it happens whatever i have
commitment issues so um i sometimes hope
that they are
[ __ ] doing something
so then i can leave the relationship
easy you try to find it out
i i give them opportunities i'll hire
some hot mail hookers to hang out and
then just be like
sure you guys don't want to hang out did
you see hotmail you know the only thing
i haven't had the confidence to do yet
is hire an eminem lookalike and have him
like hit on nikki
[Applause]
i'd be i'd be [ __ ] sweating the whole
time oh my god oh
she thinks he's hot too she swears no
but come on i'm not a [ __ ] idiot yeah
yeah
yeah
i hate with my life jesus walks again
style dude
she's got his [ __ ] brick from his old
house
wow she has like she's one of the few
like one of 500 fans of the world or
some [ __ ] who has one of his bricks from
his old house
it's on some gangster [ __ ] she likes
eminem harder than i like michael
jackson exactly and i like michael
jackson
oh bro he's
i got the glove and the jacket you mean
like a replica or the [ __ ] real one i
can't afford the real one
but if i could i would
i got a little [ __ ] embarrassed when
uh like before i shared my passcode or
whatever with with my girl like we were
on the same amazon because i had prime
so i was oh i just [ __ ] ordered it it
always starts with amazon yeah amazon's
a big thing so then i got [ __ ] kind
of embarrassed because i wasn't at that
level yet but i'd like ordered some
[ __ ] because they could see
everything you're ordering and i'd order
i had to order like a [ __ ] 10 pack of
like a hemorrhoid cream or some [ __ ]
and i was like oh [ __ ] am i here yet
like she's gonna
am i am am i okay with this did she ever
check it out if you know i
wouldn't give a [ __ ] but it's like a
thing where that's
i like that you're sitting there and
you're like just one pack of hamburger
cream that won't do
by hemorrhoids you have not seen my
hamburger that's why i said ten packs i
am gonna do a lot i have a [ __ ]
recurring [ __ ]
living nightmare where anytime i do keto
i get these [ __ ] horrible
me too horrible hemorrhoids that just
stop doing keto they [ __ ] burst
they burst and then i just have the
blood like i [ __ ] look like a bloody
purge like everything oh my god stop
doing keto this happens to you too i do
i sti the doctor's like you guys [ __ ]
doctor said the same [ __ ] i eat a lot of
veggies though with if i do keto i don't
do it anymore because i don't feel like
i can't afford the blood that's like
pure keto though that's like carnivore
[ __ ] but like if i eat veggies with my
keto that [ __ ] don't it doesn't happen
so you're not eating [ __ ] veggies
dude oh no i'm not eating any i'm just
eating [ __ ] black angus like over and
over that's like it's [ __ ] bad that's
carnivore bro i know i'm [ __ ] up but
that's why yeah you are doing a
carnivore very nice
so yeah i wasn't that that's the thing
where like that eased me into it yeah
like she knows i'm getting that many
hemorrhoids the way we started easing
into it was uh we so we got together
we're both
maybe 23 or 24 and so we're just like in
the workforce so we don't really have
much money and we wanted to travel a lot
so we started a bank account together
um and that was our first
uh travel bank account and we would each
just put i think like 200 bucks in every
single month and then so like at the
every six months we can kind of like
revisit and see
like where we want to go where we could
even afford to go and i think through
there since we had the same login to a
third bank account then we started
moving from there into our personal
account that's how she clawed into your
bank account
kind of dude kind of sketch yeah have
you guys gotten are you guys still
ordering like postmates like a
[ __ ] you you had a record as far
as people that i know who really have a
record you had the record you used to i
don't know if you still did it he orders
postmates like a production company dude
are you are you on postmates plus
unlimited
no
well you're not you're sure you're
putting money on fire bro
you can save money on every delivery
yeah it's a great 10 bucks a month and
you get like a discount i'm going to do
tonight it wipes out a pretty good
amount of the cost well you reminded me
that because you just got these toms
delivered here and you just got like
some something yeah my dad tonight then
yeah better watch can you post me a
hemorrhoid scream for me
so your girl doesn't find out yeah can
you be the guy
hey make sure the guy drives a truck
she'll see it if i do it on my phone
come on we did a lot you do this for me
yeah i think i started trusting my
girlfriend when she was like hey um i
need to get into your phone and i'm like
why oh cause i'm gonna um respond to one
of your other girlfriends and i was like
okay cool because she helps me flirt
with other girls so then at that time i
was like you know i think it's i think
it's about time you you you can actually
flirt directly like because what's the
point with me flirting with them as
usual judges don't even know what the
[ __ ] going on
wait what's going on [ __ ] amazing
yeah she's like it's a put me in coach
moment
nice yeah yeah got it she went to
varsity at that moment hey i just want
you to know
i think you're ready to [ __ ] with these
chicks
and she's like
yo man you got jk news to do like i'm
chilling at home doing jack [ __ ] let me
flirt with these girls for you score
some [ __ ] for you yeah
and it's like yo
i [ __ ] love you dude thank you is she
down is she down yeah i think she's down
to actually like
be with them and
actually
like not leave you for them yeah come to
think of it dude i think she's
just stealing them from me yeah but
she's also catfishing them right well i
haven't even got laid yet with them so
i think she's not doing a very good job
she's doing a bait and switch like a lot
of time too
you should get her passcode because she
doesn't seem trustworthy i know huh
i trust her way too much
i need to revisit this relationship
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you